uh I wanted you to hear it from me just
in case someone sees me on the street or
whatever
um I've just had two biopsies done I
just went to my doctor Dr iron who's
awesome and she just saw the little
things could be or could not be basal
cell in her opinion she doesn't know
I'll find out in two or three days and
as soon as I know I'll let you know
just to remind you basal cell in the
world of skin cancers is the least
dangerous of them all however if I can
just take this opportunity to remind you
summer is coming for those of us here in
the northern hemisphere please wear
sunscreen it is just not worth it no
matter how much you want to tan trust me
trust me trust me this is all stuff that
happened 25 years ago it's coming out
now put some sunscreen on you'll still
have an incredible time out there all
right please be safe